welcome back to New rockstars I'm Winnie
van laningham and scream has been one of
my favorite horror movies for as long as
I can remember I got so high so hyped
with a new poster for spring six drop
that I had to make a video breaking down
what it means for the next installment
of the franchise this is the first ever
screen set across the country so the
poster aptly displays the NYC subway map
as the background for a long history of
mass kills today I'm speculating on all
the subtle Clues hidden in the Scream 6
poster to kick things off let's do a
quick rundown of everything we know
about Scream 6. After surviving their
run-ins with toxic stab fandom members
Amber Freeman and Richie Kirsch sister
Sam and Tara Carpenter and twins Mindy
and Chad Meeks Martin relocate to New
York City for a fresh start in the
teaser trailer we see Mindy get attacked
by Ghostface on the subway and I'm
really hoping that she's not the
traditional First kill of the movie
because she was my absolute favorite
character from Scream 5. I'm also gonna
smoke some weed and possibly hook up
with Francis yes we are calling it
scream five because calling it scream
parentheses 2022 doesn't roll off the
tongue quite as well but Jenny Ortega
who's also set to appear in the sixth
installment of the franchise told
Entertainment Weekly that this one is
going to be especially Gore heavy to
distract us from the fact that Neve
Campbell AKA Sydney Prescott will not be
returning pay actors fairly Hollywood
scream isn't scream without Sid now
let's get into the poster at the top of
ghostface's mask all six lines red green
yellow orange blue and purple converge
at one large white spot labeled Sam
Carpenter AKA one of the protagonists
and final girls of scream 5. to refresh
your memory it was revealed that Sam's
mother had cheated on her father in high
school with Billy Loomis resulting in an
accidental pregnancy Sam's mom lied to
her entire family about her daughter's
real father and the discovery of this
news tore the family apart the other
victims are listed from top to bottom in
the reverse order of which they were
killed placing the names of each past
Ghost Face closest to Sam's name to
break down these lines I'm going to
borrow a little bit of inspiration from
my good friend James Janice over at dead
meat and do an extremely Abridged
Whitney version of a kill count he's the
true goat but I hope and make him proud
we'll start with the bottom of the red
line which features the names of
everyone killed in the original screen
the first stop we're looking at is
Maureen Prescott AKA Sydney Prescott
Smith she was killed a year prior to the
events of the original screen by
Ghostface Billy Loomis and stewmacher
who wanted her dead for breaking up
Billy's parents marriage they framed a
man named Cotton weary for her murder
and he was sent to prison but a year
after killing Maureen Billy and Stu
decided to start up the killings again
interestingly this map connects Maureen
with Stu's nephew Vince who had a
short-lived art and scream 5. the next
stop on the red line is the first
on-screen kill and scream Stephen Orr
he's disemboweled and his girlfriend
Casey Becker's backyard just before she
becomes kill number three principal
Arthur Hembree is the fourth victim
stabbed in a classroom at Woodsboro high
school next is victim 5 Tatum whose
titties get stuck in a doggy door on
Stu's garage door allowing ghost face to
crush her Kenny Brown victim six and
Gail weather's cameraman has his throat
slash little ghost face pops out of the
back of his van finally after fighting
for her life against both Stu and Billy
all movie Sidney Prescott gets the final
kills on both of them Billy gives us the
franchise's first fake out death when he
Springs back to life and lunges at them
but Sydney puts him down instantly with
a headshot but here's what's interesting
stew is supposed to be the 7th kill of
scream but if you look closely the
Little Dot next to his stop on the red
line is an extremely faint shade of
reddish pink does this mean that Stu
mocker is somehow alive now this might
be kind of a rogue Theory so I could be
reading way too much into this but if
you look at an MTA map you'll see that
the black dots represent stops on the
local line could this colored in circle
mean that Stu is a local to NYC as well
has he been living here all along biting
his time until word finally got to him
that his old buddy Billy had a daughter
what if he finds out about her move and
decides to give her a not so friendly
welcome to New York also could that
faded mask in the screen teaser be his
is that why it looks so old because he's
had it around since 1996. I don't know
the green line represents scream 2. and
first up we have Phil Stevens who is
stabbed in the ear through a movie
theater bathroom stall in the opening
scene Maureen Evans was killed moments
later while watching the in-universe
screen parody stab after Sorority Girl
CeCe Cooper is stabbed Sydney realizes
the new ghost face is killing people
with similar names to the victims of the
first screen fan favorite horror movie
expert Randy Meeks is killed in Gail's
newsman while she and Dewey race to find
Ghostface afterwards officer Andrews and
officer Richards become kills five and
six when they're killed in or on their
own cop car Mickey Altieri reveals
himself as one of the killers when he
shoots Sydney's boyfriend Derek while
he's incapacitated in the aftermath of a
frat hazing and Hallie McDaniel is
stabbed in the chest when she tries to
flee the theater Debbie Loomis who has
been going by the Alias Debbie salt
reveals herself as the second killer
seeking revenge against Sydney for the
death of her son Billy she's shot by
cotton weary and Mickey is taken down by
both Sid and Gail soon after a real
quick listen
you hear that
and that
these tracks and all the other ones we
use on new rock stars now are from
Persona music a new massive music
listening space built by creators or
creators we just started using it this
month and quite honestly we love it
Persona music offers unlimited copyright
cleared music for your videos on all
platforms under a single subscription
license their Library features music
from Marvel and Disney trailers Emmy
award-winning soundtracks and hundreds
of hit TV shows if you're a Creator
Persona music will make your life so
much easier Persona integrates with
YouTube's Content ID fingerprinting
system to detect and clear claims within
minutes just pop your channel ID and
social URLs into your user dashboard and
boom you're whitelisted all videos
published during your persona
subscription will be cleared from
Content ID claims forever take that
demonetization we like their music so
much we're using it all over our channel
to get started with Persona music just
head to
app.personamusic.io or click the link in
the description go to that pricing page
choose your plans sign up and applied
code rockstars25 at checkout to get 25
discount and one free month of persona
music on the yellow line we have Scream
3. the first stop on this line is
Christine Hamilton as a ghost face
Killing Spree hits Hollywood her
boyfriend and Scream 2 red herring
cotton weary gets gap between the eyes
and the same scene Sarah Darling is the
next kill this actress tussles with
ghosts faced in the prop Department of
stab 3 before being punched through a
window bodyguard Steve stone is the next
stop killed via knife and frying pan Tom
Prince is kill five of the movie and
Ghostface tricks him into igniting a
house filled with gas as he tries to
read Ghostface shitty screenplay by
lighter light Angelina Tyler dies next
at the start of a climactic bloodbath in
a Hollywood Mansion Tyson Fox followed
shortly after being flipped by a rug
pull and thrown off about me Parker
Posey's store brand Courtney Cox AKA
Jennifer Jolie is next to die with a
stab to the gut Mansion owner and stab
franchise producer John Milton has his
throat slit by the revealed Ghost Face
Roman Bridger who turns out to be
Sydney's secret half brother the
long-lost siblings duel it out and after
Sydney stabs him with an ice pick he
gets one last pop-up scare before Dewey
makes in the last fellow to get killed
on yellow moving on to the orange line
of 2011 scream 4. this installment's
Ghost Face kills their first victim
Marnie Cooper off screen but her stabbed
body is thrown through a window the next
stop Jenny Randall is fresh moments
later with a garage door and stabbed to
death step number three Olivia Morris is
brutally murdered as her neighbors watch
across the street next is Rebecca
Walters who is stabbed and thrown from a
parking garage stops five and six have
ghost face thin out the Woodsboro Police
Department Again by getting sneak attack
damage on Deputy Haas and detective
Perkins Kate Roberts is the next kill
with Ghostface stabbing her through the
mail slot in the door tech nerd Robbie
Mercer is kill stop number eight and
goes down telling Ghostface that his
death is a hate crime Hayden panettier's
Kirby Reed is the next kill in the movie
but you'll notice that her shop on the
poster is marked as closed Wes Craven
and Panettiere actually discussed how
her character could have potentially
survived on the film's Blu-ray
commentary in a Scream 5 easter egg
there's also a YouTube video that
confirms her survival with a recommended
video titled interview with Woods bro
Survivor Kirby Reed right next to dead
meets Cameo Panettiere is confirmed to
be making her return in Scream Six hence
the closed stop on the Orange Line
Trevor Sheldon is the next stop as Jill
Emma Roberts is revealed to be the
surprise second ghost face of this film
being her Unfaithful ex Trevor gets a
bullet in the dick and then one in the
head Roberts then stabs her partner
Charlie Walker making him stop number
11. Sid then makes her younger cousin
the final stop on Orange by frying her
with the defibrillator and shooting her
to keep her down our last line with
named stops is the blue line of Scream 5
beginning with kill number one Ben
Schneider Sheriff Judy Hicks and her son
Wes are stabbed in their home as victims
two and three but once again Ghostface
goes on a cop kill and spree Deputy
Clays killed off screen and his bodies
left for Terror to find and our Mass
Killers get away with with icing Dewey
Riley after nine previous stabbings this
dude had to go sometime but his loss
still makes me really sad annoying team
Liz has her brains blown out by Amber
Freeman in one of the most violent
deaths in Scream history Richie is
stabbed through the face and in the dick
by Sam who warns him not to [ __ ] with
the daughter of a serial killer before
slicing and Dyson Amber is shot by Gail
and subsequently set on fire by the
kitchen stove she does pop up again like
all Supreme villains do but Tara hits
her with the final kill shot with the
purple line left blank to keep scream
6's victims a secret for now there's no
telling how many bodies this train line
will stack up with but I want to know
what you guys think in the comments will
Stu return how did Kirby survive and
what has she been doing since well Mindy
lived through ghostface's subway attack
I need to know follow me on Instagram
and Twitter whitneypuppy falling
rockstars subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
foreign
[Music]
[Music]